are you wanting to learn how to pressure can but you're worried about the safety
we've all heard stories of great Aunt Edith
who had a pressure canner blow up and cover the ceiling with spaghetti sauce
but how common is that and how do you prevent it
so home pressure canners were developed around the beginning of World War Two
but production was brought to a halt due to the war efforts and aluminum rations
after the war ended
demand for pressure cookers and canners skyrocketed
production boomed
but many of the pressure canners and cookers were low quality
introducing the flying lids and explosions
canners from the 50s had several issues
you can do your own research into the individual problems
but the good thing is that by the 1970s
they figured out how to fix the problems and improve the product
today's canners are made with safety measures and backups
to ensure that flying lids are a thing of the past
they're also tested rigorously for home safety
if the safety mechanisms are not engaged
the canner will not even build a pressure
so what is the safest canner
basically any canner that's newer than 1970
my favorite pressure canner is a vintage one from the 80s
works like a charm
be sure to buy a reputable brand like Presto or all American
don't buy a cheap knockoff and you'll be fine
are you interested in pressure canning
you can get my beginner guide by commenting the word ebook
see you there